[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
locales et régionales de la tnt tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité
dont tu mille panneaux installés sur 20
hectares la plus importante ferme
solaire de bretagne entrera en service à
la rentrée elle produira l'équivalent de
la consommation électrique annuelle de
5000 foyers les hits guider dans un
instant avec tvr la chaîne de rennes en
ille journal elle nous informe même en
plein mois d'août la pqr presse
quotidienne régionale ne cesse de se
réinventer
notamment pendant les vacances vous
verrez vous en parlerons avec notre
invité guilhem méric avis le directeur
des rédactions du journal la provence et
puis en fin de journal vous découvrez un
jardin unique en son genre le jardin
extraordinaire de brest fleurs et arbres
du monde entier pousse sur les terres de
la bretagne
elle est inépuisable l'énergie solaire
se développe partout en france près de
rennes une ferme solaire est en cours de
finalisation dès la rentrée prochaine 38
mille panneaux solaires fonctionneront
pour fournir les besoins en électricité
de 5000 foyers les coulisses de la plus
grande ferme solaire de bretagne un
reportage de la rédaction locale de tvn
nous vous parlions ces dernières
semaines de la ferme solaire installée
sur l'ancien carreau de la mine de
pont-péan une visite sur site vient
d'être organisée en présence des élus de
rennes métropole de bruay de pont-péan
puisque le terrain de 20 hectares est à
cheval sur les deux communes trente-huit
mille panneaux installés pour une
puissance de 15 mégawatts soit
l'équivalent de la consommation annuelle
de 5000 foyers un site idéal exposé
plein sud sur un terrain inexploitables
pour la construction ou l'agriculture et
surtout un atout il est au coeur de la
métropole on vient de produire de
l'énergie pour qu'elle soit consommer
local elle va être consommée localement
sur l'agglomération rennaise aussi
techniquement on a toutes tous les
réseaux de l'agglomération qui nous
permet de nous raccorder très facilement
et de raccorder beaucoup de puissance
électrique et c'est vraiment là le
l'enjeu d'un projet solaire c'est le
raccordement au réseau et c'est là le
bon dimensionnement électrique
généralement les grosses centrales sont
sont isolés en milieu rural là on est
très proches vers un centre urbain et
c'est intéressant la ferme solaire sera
mise en service en septembre il reste
quelques panneaux à monter puis à
raccorder au réseau le financement
participatif auquel étaient invités les
habitants a été un succès 1 millions
d'euros levés en l'espace de trois
semaines
manger bio locale et réduire ses déchets
la tâche paraît compliqué a priori elle
l'est de moins en moins en réalité les
épiceries locales se multiplient un peu
partout sur tout le territoire dans
l'oise vous allez le voir deux amis
julie et julie se sont associés pour
ouvrir leur boutique avec des produits
locaux et écologique leur projet a mûri
pendant le confinement un sujet de
michael joly pour vyas 95 dans l'oise
déconfiture produite dans les yvelines
des légumes valdoisiens des bières du
vexin et du pastis parisien nous sommes
à eragny sur oise dans l'épicerie de
julie ici on trouve exclusivement des
produits locaux du vrac et du bio une
première sur l'agglomération
cergypontaines derrière cette boutique
ouverte en octobre 2020 julie levant
tour et julie poinsignon idée en fait
c'était de pouvoir faire ses courses
dans un seul magasin ne pas avoir à
courir dans 36 magasins
et de voir enfin parce que voilà ça
prend du temps encore une fois le zéro
déchet prend du temps et on voulait
épargner en fait ce temps là aux femmes
qui font les courses et donc pour ça
qu'on n'est pas que sur du rac et qu'on
ait une épicerie avec vocation zéro
déchet
mais packer zéro déchet car ici les
clients utilisent leurs propres
contenants ou ceux fournis par la
boutique pour réduire les emballages
amies et voisines l'idée de cette
épicerie est venu au jury durant la
période de confinement imposées par la
crise de lakovic 19 on a continué de
famille ensemble ces deux enfants mes
deux enfants et nos projets respectifs
donc du mal à s'approvisionner pendant
le confinement moi j'avais déjà cette
idée d'épicerie vrakking trottait dans
la tête depuis depuis quelques mois un
jour je n'en avais déjà parlé à julie et
un jour je lui dis vraiment là si mon
âme une épicerie vrai qu'en match chez
nous ce serait parfait on aurait pas de
problèmes tant ce pour s'approvisionner
et elle m'a dit allez on y va une
reconversion professionnelle pour sept
secrétaires médicales et sa voisine chef
de projet dans un grand groupe ensemble
elle cherche un local contracte un
emprunt y lance une cagnotte sur
internet un succès avec plus de 10000
euros collectés résultat presque six
mois plus tard cette épicerie et pour
les clients le besoin et elle a donc
déjà n'y avait pas ce genre de service
là ou alors il fallait vraiment aller
sur d'autres centres commerciaux là on
peut quand on habite dans le village
déjà c'est pas mal parce qu'il n'ya pas
grand chose aux alentours en fait depuis
que j'ai eus livia qui a 5 ans j'ai un
peu changé tout mon mode de consommation
et je veux plutôt du local surtout je
prie connaît surtout à ça le local et
j'ai trouvé ça génial au total la
boutique propose 1500 références de
produits et les julie prévoit encore
d'augmenter leur offre elle espère
trouver un approvisionnement en fruits
bio locaux
la vie culturelle reprend peu à peu ses
droits en france heureusement sur la
côte d'azur la petite ville de saint
jean cap ferrat inaugure une exposition
d'art contemporain art rivera tour c'est
son nom qui réunit trente artistes
minutieusement sélectionnés de la
peinture la sculpture de l'art numérique
du design aussi des artistes aux univers
très différents mais toujours très
talentueux comme vous allez le voir le
maire de saint jean cap ferrat
jean-françois dietrich nous parle de
l'impact la période qu'ovide sur la
culture dans sa commune le coc vide nous
a quand même ralenti beaucoup j'irai
même annulé toute l'activité artistique
et c'est vrai que c'est la seconde
activité artistique les seuls en
événements culturels que nous proposons
aujourd'hui avec la semaine dernière une
très belle exposition dadaïste et puis
on enchaîne aujourd'hui sur une
exposition d'art contemporain qui réunit
un certain nombre de talents aujourd'hui
on marie d'autres arrêtent à sculpture
également du mobilier et qui va donner
une dimension tout à fait intéressante
lire à cet événement et cette exposition
c'est une première collection que
j'expose donc oui ça jacob ferrat était
pour moi une
mais rose occasion moi j'adore l'acier
inoxydable c'est un matériau très
résistant puis très pur il roule pas
puis bry très fort on peut le travailler
et on a tous eu des effets de micro
miroirs brossé l'acier
et puis après
je pouvais pas m'empêcher d'y rajouter
quelque chose
le feu faut qu'une sculpture vivent
elles doivent donner ce plaisir en la
regardant pas seulement parce que c'est
un beau dessin mais parce que on lui
projette une lumière elle la reflète et
là quelque chose qui vit
les jeux olympiques de tokyo à peine
terminée place désormais aux jeux
paralympiques du 24 août au 5 septembre
prochain deux semaines de compétition et
d'efforts pour les meilleurs sportifs
mondiaux en situation de handicap
l'occasion aussi de s'intéresser à une
pratique méconnue mais qui se développe
le rugby fauteuil un sport qui demande
force précision mais aussi endurance à
limoges le rugby fauteuil est déjà bien
ancré à reportage de benjamin delmas de
7 à limoges la chaîne locale sur place
où l'on inventé au canada en 1906 de 16
il oppose deux équipes de quatre joueurs
sur un plancher de terrain de basket la
spécificité ça va être un handicap déjà
qui va toucher les tétraplégiques ou
toute personne c'est signé tetra donc
c'est le seul sport collectif qu'on va
trouver pour proscrire de handicap et
ben c'est un jeu de contact c'est
impressionnant donc ouais c'est pas mal
ici pas de ballon ovale on utilise un
ballon vole être plus facile à manier
chaque joueur est classé en fonction de
son invalidité les plus habiles joue en
attaque les autres en défense alors du
coup moi je fais du rugby donc en valais
l'accident et c'est tout naturellement
voilà un sport on retrouve un peu
l'esprit d'équipé le combat là peut-être
la combativité voix c'est très très
intéressant car le soir se voient leur
ca au sein de l'effectif de la section
rugby fauteuil de lui c'est l'image
figurent jean françois ducay médaillé
d'argent paralympiques un eagle de
londres tennis de table a rangé les
raquettes pour se consacrer au rugby
fauteuil je suis un ancien rugbyman donc
voilà de retrouver ses valeurs même si
le ballon est rond et voilà qu'on a
droit de faire des passes en avant mais
voilà il ya toujours cette entrée dans
l'équipe on est quatre sur le terrain
mais on est sept ou huit dans l'équipe
plus les coaches plus nos les mécanos
corne a une super équipe les fauteuils
sont carénées ceux des défenseurs ont
des grilles sont conçus pour bloquer le
fauteuil de l'adversaire le fauteuil de
l'attaquant est profilé pour marquer ce
sport est une discipline paralympique
depuis les jeux de sydney 2000
aujourd'hui il compte plus de 260
licenciés en france et 16 clubs affiliés
et un jeu de position donc on va
avoir des joueurs qui vont pouvoir faire
des blocs protéger un joueur qui va être
un peu handicapé pour monter le ballon
et lui en fait et va utiliser plus
petits points parce qu'on appelait les
joueurs les plus handicapés avec leur
leur grille qui ont bloqué les autres
joueurs et salomé pouvoir les marques et
les sections rugby fauteuil de lui c'est
l'image déjà les yeux rivés sur la
saison prochaine elle recrute d'ailleurs
de nouveaux joueurs
ils sont au coeur de l'actualité de ce
mois d'août les pompiers éteindre les
incendies nous courir quand nous sommes
en danger leurs missions sont évidemment
importantes pour nous tous et pour la
sécurité publique et pour devenir
pompier bien la formation est longue et
compliquée la rédaction de via occitanie
a suivi le parcours d'un jeune
sapeur-pompier romane elle a 15 ans et
elle a une vie d'adolescente presque
comme les autres mais dans le feu de
l'action regardez
le vendredi elle termine le lycée à 12h
à 14h elle s'enferme dans sa chambre
pour faire ses devoirs à 15 ans romane a
tout d'une jeune fille de son âge sauf
peut être cette paire de rangers ce noir
qui traînent dans sa chambre des
chaussures militaires qui font partie de
tout un équipement ça c'est ma casquette
que joue mais pour les cérémonies j'ai
mes gants pour les manoeuvres et j'ai
mon cinq jours en concert pour accrocher
mes gants romane et je me sapeur pompier
volontaire depuis l'âge de 13 ans une
fois par semaine elle apprend les gestes
qui viennent à bout d'un ce et ceux qui
savent au fond de soi c'est se sentir
important elle faire ça comme ça dans
les dents la population parce qu'on est
beaucoup moins haut
et se surpasser
se surpasser
raccordé ouvrait
ce samedi matin à l'école des jsp de
lunel une voiture a pris feu un cas
fictif il a fallu en dépit
d'accords passés de bonnes productions
entre lève on se relève et en progrès
avec roumanie ils sont une quinzaine à
passer l'exercice
objectif savoir manipuler les tuyaux
tout en se synchronisant avec son binôme
ce qui me plaît ce que on est tout le
temps dans dans l'effort physique
moi j'aime j'aime bien ça on est
toujours poussé par nos enseignants et
on a un bel esprit collectif et c'est ça
que j'aime bien chez eux cet exercice
est un test pour permettre aux jsp de
passer une troisième année ça s'est bien
passé pour moi en tant que chef mais
après avec mon équipier il a eu quelques
lacunes donc ça nous a un peu pénalisé
mais ce barrage d je vais passer avec
marouane normalement donc ya pas de
raison que ça se passe mal
l'école de lunel a été créé en 2018 est
l'un de ses auteurs c'est steve ça peut
être compliqué pour eux parce que oui
ils sont jeunes mais justement on est là
pour faire en sorte d'arriver à pallier
à ce stress aux pronostics risque du
danger est quelqu'un qui est pas
stressés qui va très confiant bien
souvent c'est l'arrivée les accidents et
donc on est là pour les mener parce
qu'un peu à la faute pour éviter
justement qu'ils les fassent quand il ya
de la pression dans l'eau comme c'est à
lui sur à lui l'a lu sur la lui ça
glisse ce pain d'accord c'est ça qui
nous embêtent donc essayé au lieu de
forcer comme ça essayez de vous ramener
un peu et ça viendra tout seul d'accord
parce que vous avez par pour beaucoup
à l'issue de cette formation de quatre
ans ces jeunes recevront le brevet
national de jeune sapeur pompier ils
pourront ainsi intégrer le corps des
sapeurs pompiers volontaires de lunel et
dès l'âge de 18 ans ou pas c'est
peut-être le concours pour devenir
pompier professionnel
eux aussi font preuve de courage les
journalistes de la presse quotidienne
régionale la pqr comme on l'appelle ne
s'arrête jamais pour vous informer même
pendant les grandes vacances il profite
d'ailleurs de la période pour vous
distiller quelques conseils et
informations touristiques c'est le cas
notamment du journal la provence dont
nous sommes partenaires ici dans le
grand jt des territoires nous sommes
d'ailleurs en duplex avec le directeur
des rédactions du journal du sud-est
guilhem rica vie bonjour guilhem votre
journal prévoit-il des pages ou des
cahiers spéciaux pour cet été car j'ai
remarqué sur votre site internet une
rubrique dédiée qui s'appelle c'est
l'été oui en effet cette année encore on
a décidé d'habiller la provence pour la
période estivale pendant deux mois avec
des habits d'été comprenez des rubriques
spécifiques liés à cette saison des
loisirs des idées sorties beaucoup de
cultures parce que il y à de très
nombreux rendez-vous en la matière dans
la région et puis tout ce qui donne
envie au journal et à l'extérieur chaque
jour on propose une terrasse un café un
restaurant un glacier à découvrir et
puis on se veut aussi très pédagogue
avec les vacanciers qui sont chez nous
on s'intéresse au parler d'ici du sud le
par les marseillais notamment avec la
chronique d'un linguiste médéric gasquet
cyrus qui nous donne les expressions qui
peut faire sourire lorsqu'on n'est pas
de la région
comment le journal et les journalistes
traitent ils de l'information en période
estivale est-ce que vous privilégiez des
actualités plus légères par exemple qu'à
l'accoutumée alors effectivement c'est
une bonne question parce qu'à la fois on
traite l'actualité telle qu'elle se
présente on a choisit pas mais à côté de
ça eh bien on essaie de profiter de
l'été pour un peu souffler coupées ont
proposé bien des thématiques plus légère
des magazines des reportages et
notamment pour re découvrir les richesse
les pépites de notre si belle région
cette période estivale c'est aussi
l'occasion de toucher un autre public au
fond
alors c'est sûr que la provence à ses
lecteurs fidèles habituels qui nous
lisent parce qu'ils savent qu'ils vont
trouver l'information sportive notamment
un mais c'est également une carte
postale importante pour les vacanciers
qui attendent de la provence qu'elle
proposait bien des idées de sorties
quand on n'est pas de la région on vient
passer une semaine que ce soit à avignon
arles dans les alpes de haute provence
ou à la limite du var et là les
vacanciers ont besoin de la provence
pour savoir quoi faire que faire et quoi
découvrir pendant leur séjour qu'il aime
un cas vis des nouveautés sont elles à
prévoir pour la rentrée dans la provence
et ses éditions locales par exemple
alors il ya toujours beaucoup de
nouveautés dans un journal c'est quelque
chose de vivant un journal et que ce
soit sur laprovence.com notre site
internet ou dans nos éditions et bien
papier oui il y aura des nouveautés on
en train de réfléchir d'ailleurs à ce
que doit être le journal de demain
comprenez celui qui sera le plus en
phase avec les attentes de nos lecteurs
du papier et puis de notre site internet
merci guy l'america vie d'avoir été
invité le grand jt des territoires
évidemment pour le reste de l'été on
retrouve la provence sur internet et
bien sûr dans tous les kiosques de la
région où elle est diffusée
ouvrons à présent dans ce grand jt des
territoires une page d'histoire et
tourisme au mans l'office de tourisme
local organise cet été des visites
guidées pour le moins original vous
allez le voir du centre historique un
parcours permet notamment de retracer
l'histoire des maisons closes de la
ville les traces de ce passé sont encore
nombreuses dans les ruelles et sur des
bâtiments découverte avec hélène galiana
pour vyas lmtv sartre sur place
pour vous plonger dans l'histoire
imaginez vous à la fin du 19e siècle
logement n'est alors qu'un endroit pas
très chaleureux très pauvre et délabré
les élèves et surtout des rues entières
de maisons closes
alors là on est dans les pans de gorron
les pans de gorron c'est en contrebas de
la cathédrale de l'évêché et c'est un
lieu où il y avait énormément de maisons
closes au numéro 1 au numéro quatre au
numéro 7 normalement elle devait être
repérable
impénétrable par les yeux non ouvertes
sauf pour faire le ménage c'est écrit
dans les règlements et la tenancière est
donc toujours une femme doit avoir c'est
une demande d'inscription pour cette
maison et les femmes qui sont avec elles
doivent être normalement encartés c'est
à dire avoir une carte professionnelle
en 1889 ont dénombré environ 150
prostituées déclaré officieusement il y
en avait deux tiers de plus alors ici on
arrive devant le 3 de la rue de la
verrerie qui était l'établissement
sanitaire alors ça paraît incroyable
mais cette maison qui est aujourd'hui
une maison privée était donc l'hôpital
où on dirait la maison réservé aux
visites médicales les maisons ont fermé
au moins en 1946 après la loi marthe
richard ancienne femme de joie qui a
milité pour leur fermeture il reste
aujourd'hui de nombreux vestiges et la
ville du mans propose régulièrement des
visites pour apprendre à percer leur
mystère
et de l'histoire il en sera évidemment
question dans le prochain film du
réalisateur martiniquais patrick bos la
la couleur de l' esclavage c'est le nom
de ce film documentaire qui doivent
sortir à la fin de l'année pour le
moment l'heure est encore aux tournages
et à la préparation des costumes comme
le voyez sur ces images de nos
partenaires sur place via atv dans ce
film patrick bos la racontera notamment
le quotidien des esclaves travaillaient
sans relâche dans les champs de canne à
sucre écoutez le à ce propos au micro de
loïc régis sur place il s'agit par
aucune position du quoi que ce soit je
ne suis pas historien j'essaie de faire
comme j'ai fait à travers les autres
films que j'ai déjà réalisé de raconter
tout simplement notre patrimoine notre
culture notre histoire en ce qui
concerne ce film
au plus près de la réalité de ce que ce
qui a été dit ce qui a été écrit donc
j'essaie d'aller au plus profond et
comme dans tous mes films je vais quand
même loin il ya des choses qu'on va
prendre encore une fois il a il s'agit
de faire les scènes d'ensemble où la
coupe de la canne a commencé il faut
qu'on ait de belles images de la
martinique en même temps qu'on raconte
cette histoire et donc il faut beaucoup
de monde parce que dans les plantations
à l'époque il y avait des centaines
d'esclaves on referme cette page
consacrée à l'histoire de nos
territoires en corse avec le passé de
l'île rousse située tout au nord de
l'île de beauté ce territoire
reconnaissable à la couleur de ses
granit roux est constitué de huit îlots
ils sont reliés depuis peu au port de
commerce et connaissent un essor
touristique très important les
précisions historiques recueillis par
via télé pas aisée stéphane bern ots la
hauteur du livre line seul à l'île
rousse
sur la gauche ici donc vous avez route
euros choo ici sur la droite vous avez
route chez tous qui est plus petit lille
qui est derrière nous il ya le phare
c'est lise le grain des livres de la
piètre ici on se trouve donc à
l'intérieur des îlots on est dans lé ans
de photo nature alors fanta nature
pourquoi parce que juste ici sur la
gauche on a une petite fontaine qui date
de l'époque génoise donc c'est 17e 16ème
17ème siècle est ici sept 7 ans naturel
qui a été le premier port de l'île
rousse ici à l'époque préhistorique
c'était le port 1 bien sûr le point
culminant de l'île de la piètre c'est le
farsi avec le phare mais avant il y
avait un poste de tir c'est à dire qu'à
l'epoque des génois c'est le 16ème
siècle c'est le 17e siècle il y avait un
poste de tir à la place du phare alors
l'utilité de la torre noah c'était tout
simplement de défendre ici le petit port
kinky naturel en donc il fallait à tout
prix éviter que les bateaux viennent ici
que les hommes débarquent et qu'ils
aillent dans la ville pillé et dérobé
des choses et il fallait à tout prix que
les génois empêche cela
dans les vosges le festival nature
images se poursuit cet été c'est la
quatorzième édition comme celle de l'an
passé elle s'est adaptée évidemment à la
coved 19 les expositions se tiennent en
extérieur elles sont gratuites parmi
elles celle de la nature à l'oeil une
exposition de photos géantes d'animaux
sauvages et des tailles de tirer la
leçon et de nicholas bray d'art pour
vosges télévision
patience et longueur de temps font plus
que force ni que rage cette morale de la
fontaine résume assez bien les deux
qualités essentielles pour réussir un
bon cliché de ce qu'on peut apprécier
depuis ce week-end et jusque fin
septembre en accès libre et gratuitement
sur les façades extérieures de tiny
cours près de monture sur saône
l'association nature images il propose
cette exposition de 80 photos on a été
l'année dernière la mort dans l'âme
obligé de la nuit festival on a rebondi
sur un projet d'expo extérieur qui a
connu une grosse fréquentation et cette
année on a presque doublé le nombre
d'image avant l'épidémie l'événement
recevait tout de même près de 3500
visiteurs autre temps autre façon de
procéder parmi les exposants teddy
bracquart chargé d'études
environnementales à pompe et en meurthe
et moselle ce photographe de 26 ans et
plusieurs fois primé notamment pour ses
photos de grands mammifères est tombé
dedans très jeune donc au début c'était
aller dans la nature observer les
oiseaux comme on construit des cabanes
comment voilà tous les gosses comme tous
les gosses c'est finalement une passion
qui ne cessera de grandir mais du loup
de l'ours ou du lynx qui se prête le
moins à la photo le plus dur il est
large le plus dure celle là un mythe de
la forêt en fantôme c'est un animal sur
lequel on va passer des heures et des
heures ou des jours des mois des années
piste et à traquer avant de pouvoir le
rencontrer après avoir été braconnés le
lynx avait disparu de nos forêts mais
depuis 2000 vingt deux trois cinq
individus ont été recensées dans le
massif heures remontant du jura franco
suisse ou issus de lâcher en rhénanie
palatinat en allemagne l'âme ces animaux
a d'ailleurs été abattu dans le
haut-rhin tirer une espèce protégée
c'est faire preuve d'un manque
d'intelligence tout simplement après
lorraine par nature tu es libre à car
dédicacer ce week-end son deuxième
ouvrage paru à 1000 exemplaires en auto
édition est intitulé sauvage par nature
quant au village de tignes est court il
sera les 14 et 15 août prochain le
théâtre d'un festival plein air
organisée par nature images
voilà que diriez vous d'un tour du monde
botanique maintenant pour terminer ce
grand jt c'est le voyage entrepris par
80 passionnés en plein coeur de brest
grâce au budget participatif attribué
par la métropole ces jardiniers
bénévoles plantes depuis un an des
espèces venues des quatre coins du monde
pour constituer un extraordinaire jardin
de 7000 m² au pied du port de commerce
car oui absolument tout peut pousser à
brest comme nous l'expliquent pauline
fercot de la chaîne tébéo et tv sud la
chaîne du groupe le télégramme sur place
depuis 35 ans jacques consacre son temps
libre à son jardin en plein coeur de
brest ce grand voyageur passionné de
plantes exotiques a établi la preuve
vivante que sous le climat brestois tout
pousse sujet 25 euros environ je les
portais faisait 80 cm de l'eau même les
agrumes preuve en est ce citronniers se
tordre le produit après 25 ans de deux
pointeurs il produit une cinquantaine de
kilos par an et cet excellent os en
confiture une passion qu'il n'est pas
seul à partager à brest puisque avec
d'autres botaniste passionnés ils ont
décroché en 2019 le premier prix du
budget participatif de la ville pour
développer un jardin extraordinaire des
plantes venant d'australie 2
de mexique d'afrique du sud et d'asie en
fait toutes les plantes ici s'acclimate
beaucoup sont des dons et 80 bénévoles
se relaient chaque semaine pour
défricher désherber planter tailler et
même escaladé et ancien alpiniste
escaladeurs donc ça me donne un certain
avantage pour aller sur les falaises et
si moi je suis amateur de plantes
succulentes principalement et puis de
plantes général donc en fait j'arrive à
vos yeux de l'ensemble des choses qui me
pèse une diversité botanique qui est un
vrai plus pour la biodiversité en ville
quand on est arrivé sur ce site il ne
pousse est quasiment que des plantes
dites invasives là depuis que nous
allons planter donc 500 espèces qu'ils
reportent à peu près 1500 plants
forcément il y aura beaucoup plus de
floraison et surtout en fait répartis
sur toute l'année donc c'est une aubaine
pour pour les insectes pollinisateurs
puisqu'il aura mangé toute l'année après
dix-huit mois de plantation le jardin
prend forme et couleur il ouvre ses
portes au public aux grandes occasions
et ressemblera sûrement un jour à
l'extraordinaire jardin de jacques
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur aux chaînes locales et régionales de
la tnt et sur tv5 monde on se retrouve
pour une prochaine édition aura tout ça
très vite
[Musique]